selling all day all right my we don't
are you gonna sell oh come on Cabrera
just grounded into a double play Matt
set this up I told it was a family
discussion I think it is I don't think
you should sell it all I'm telling you I
expected I got so upset about I am I am
upset about it why do you care I don't
know one thing I think film can do
really well better than any other medium
is capture the reality of conversations
in a book no matter how you lay it out
one piece of dialogue always has to
follow another you can't simulate people
talking over each other which is what we
all do a lot of the time and you can't
really capture the rhythm speed and tone
that a conversation has even radio and
theater miss some of the nuances that
film is perfectly suited to reproduce of
all the filmmakers working right now
I think Noah Baumbach maybe has the best
ear for dialogue as it really is and an
ear is what it takes because there's a
general disconnect between what we all
sound like and what movie and TV
characters sound like especially the
most articulate ones you asked me that
moronic question and then my world came
apart and she came here and I landed in
the tabloids and I got death threats and
my job is constantly in jeopardy
and you ruined my life consciousness yes
that was me of course you don't have to
aim at realistic speech screenwriters
like Aaron Sorkin and Quentin Tarantino
have done really great work by writing
human dialogue as it could be finding
music and language the same way that
Shakespeare did centuries ago but
Bombeck on the other hand seems to be
committed to a different principle you
know I think I mentioned to you I left
the company I was with I mean a couple
of other people started our own firm
it was scary and a big change but things
have settled and we're doing really well
Maureen is talking to a friend working
the time about getting someone to come
up and review the show people in recent
years I've essentially didn't ignore
work great alternative to some of it I
think this might put me back on the map
this is our logo fifty-five dollars for
a stake I think the conversation like
this speaks volumes in one sense just by
looking at it you can see that this is a
total failure of communication between
father and son the two men are on
parallel tracks matt is talking about
his new business and Harold is talking
about his forthcoming art retrospective
but in another sense what makes this
exchange so heartbreaking and true to
life at least for me is that they really
are communicating with each other just
not explicitly Matt brings up a major
life change and expresses some of the
hopes and fears he has about it and his
father immediately brings up his own
major life event and some of the hopes
and fears he has about that implicitly
matt is asking for approval he's asking
for reassurance and he's asking for
consolation Harold on the other hand is
denying approval because he can't bear
his son being more successful than he is
while asking for reassurance of his own
hopes and consolation for his own fears
it's like the two men are firing a
volley of missiles at each other some
are hitting some are missing and some
are crashing into each other in midair
I think Bombeck understands a key
dynamic in conversations especially
conversations with family when we speak
to others
we're often speaking to ourselves
attempting to frame dialogue so that the
person were talking to will reflect back
the things that we want to believe about
us when I was younger I was so invested
in his grievances his anger the world
they were mine too but now that I lived
3,000 miles away and have my own kid
thriving business I I don't even get
angry at him anymore and see we just
funny I'm sure a lot of people who just
went home for Thanksgiving experienced
something like this you feel that you've
changed that you have an updated nuanced
idea of yourself and you're gonna show
that idea in one way or another to your
family the thing we seem to forget is
that as we're trying to get our family
to affirm our sense of self they're
doing the same thing to us and the
result is often conflict or a
conversation that just goes nowhere
well maybe not no we're just not where
you intended that's as you started your
own company yeah a couple other guys you
just tell your boss like I'm gonna start
I was one of the partners so it
integrity have a boss no I understand so
you got a better offer no there were no
offers that's what was so scary we were
creating our own opportunity because you
wanted something smaller bigger this is
my favorite scene in the movie it's a
minute and 30 second long take of two
half-brothers attempting to connect by
making it one take you get all the
elements of conversation that I spoke
about before including the body language
the projected self-confidence of Matt
and the nervous and secure energy of
Danny always nodding his head like his
father they're doing this thing where
they agree while also disagreeing it's a
specific kind of non argument that tells
you a lot about their personalities and
their relationship many of the firm's
clients came with us which was
surprising
no we expect it we can't legally ask
clients
come with out they don't have much
choice it's totally their choice no I
know because you have their money okay
there's so much going on here on one
level Danny is trying to connect with
Matt by literally trying to finish his
sentences he's also trying to challenge
him and assert some dominance by acting
like he knows what Matt's gonna say next
talk about speaking to yourself Danny is
effectively trying to hijack Matt's
sentences and make them his own listen
for this the next time you're in a
conversation people do this all the time
well their money is with the firm that
their money is in investments my buddy
told me who lives across the street I
lived across the street dad told me
about your Karen is like you I'm sorry
so arbitrage yeah that's not what I do
at this point Matt and Danny are getting
out of sync which actually makes it
appropriate that Danny brings up
arbitrage an investment term for when
the same asset is worth different values
in different places and you exploit that
price difference for profit exploiting
differences in value is a pretty good
definition of what it's like to be in a
dysfunctional family or a dysfunctional
conversation for that matter it's all Ma
said that the system is rigged from the
inside that's not entirely true
but mostly so this is an exciting time
how does your boy good Victoria and I
are having some problems I never met her
Karen and I separated I know I just said
I was sorry
did you I'm sorry too and there it is a
moment of connection one minute and 13
seconds into the conversation in the
meyerwitz family moments of connection
are few and far between so when they
happen they land with a special
poignancy and though this family is
perhaps more intense more insecure than
most i hope there's something that rings
so true about this to me when we talk so
often we fly around each other working
out our own thinking about
ourselves we try to make our meaning
clear but we can't quite say what we
want how we want when we want
that's because communication isn't easy
sometimes movies make it seem like it is
but Noah Baumbach isn't interested in
that kind of
he uses the medium best suited for
depicting conversations to show us the
truth about them that we miss the mark
more often than we hidden and that it's
a beautiful meaningful thing when we do
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the questions I get asked the
most by far is what kind of software do
I use to make these videos to edit I use
Final Cut Pro 10 and since 10 is so
different from the programs that came
before it
I actually depended a lot on online
videos to teach me the new features
these days you can pretty much teach
yourself anything this way and
Skillshare is the perfect way to do it
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
16,000 classes in graphic design
animation web development video game
design and more all the classes are
professional and understandable and
follow a clear learning curve a Premium
Membership begins around $10 a month for
unlimited access to all the courses but
the first 500 people to sign up using
the first link in the description will
get a 2 month free trial in those 2
months you could easily learn the skills
you need to start a new hobby or
business specialized skills like
learning After Effects which I've always
wanted to do and Skillshare has dozens
of classes that will help you master
that program what's the skill that
you've been putting off learning why not
sign up the skill share using the link
below and start learning right away you
got nothing to lose and a valuable skill
to gain thanks guys I'll see you next
time